Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, hopefully most
of you have had a chance to see the Walking
Dead Finale.
I already did my Q&A video answering as many
of the big questions from the episode.
So now it’s time to talk about Season 5,
because they’ve already started releasing
news.
So what I’m going to do is start with things
that are confirmed and then do my Top 10 predictions
based on what we know so far.
A lot of you have been asking about what kind
of videos I’m doing now that the season
is over.
I’m going to try and do one Walking Dead
video per week and at least three per month.
More when there’s big news to talk about.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything if
you’re finding me for the first time.
Dragons are coming this week.
Walking Dead big news of the day is that Gareth,
Tara and Rosita have all been bumped to series
regulars for Season 5.
This tells us that one, those characters probably
aren’t going to die anytime soon and it
means that we might be spending more time
at Terminus than expected.
As in multiple episodes.
I’ll talk more about that during predictions,
but let’s try to answer this really big
question first.
If Rosita is a series regular why aren’t
Abraham and Eugene too?
Series regular means you appear in more episodes,
get more lines.
Get paid a lot more.
I think it means Abraham and Eugene will be
taking a road trip without Rosita and that
will just occur off screen for the most part.
Now that all the groups are together the first
part of season 5 will probably all just happen
at Terminus.
On to predictions.
So careful for spoilers from the show and
the comic if you’re not caught up.
Here’s my top 10.
Starting with Number 10 - Abraham and Eugene
will separate from the group and bolt for
Alexandria.
During my Q&A I talked about Cannibals eating
the biggest people first and clearly Abraham
and Eugene would top the list after Tyreese,
but their characters just have way too much
story left in the comics.
Even if the show remixes everything that’s
supposed to come next, they’d still be a
part of it.
But since they’re not series regulars, having
their story literally “travel” off screen
would be a good way to start throwing to Alexandria.
Abraham’s whole mission has been to get
Eugene to DC and he has that stubborn military
mindset and he’s not going to stop until
he accomplishes the mission.
Number 9 - Tyreese, Carol and Judith will
still be on the road
There was that lingering shot of powdered
milk outside traincar A that made everyone
wonder if it was being used to feed baby Judith,
but after staring at it a third and fourth
time I think it’s just what they were using
to feed the survivors that we saw, Glenn and
Maggie’s group.
Scott Gimple also said something vague on
Talking Dead about them being out there somewhere.
We already know Beth’s story is going to
diverge from the rest of the Survivors for
most of the season.
It’s also possible that Carol, Tyreese and
Judith could sidestep Terminus all together.
They’ve already confirmed that there will
be more action in season 5, and wouldn’t
having a baby right there kill all that tension.
Rick would do a complete 180 back to farmer
Rick.
So I think that they won’t show up at Terminus,
at least, not while shit is going down between
the Survivors and the cannibals.
As much as I want to see Rick and Carl reunited
with Judith, by not being there, she’ll
be spared being turned into a hamburger.
Number 8 - The first half of the season will
all be at Terminus
Gareth is a series regular now, there wouldn’t
be a reason to make him one if the Survivors
were going to blow right through on their
way to Alexandria.
So them escaping and defeating the cannibals
is just going to cross over several episodes.
Which I think is great, they teased so much
mythology in the five actual minutes of Terminus
we saw.
We’ll get to learn all about the creepy
religion they practice, what the candles are
for and the history of Terminus.
They wrote those creepy mantra’s on the
wall for a reason.
Clearly the Saviors or someone bad came there
at some point and took advantage of them.
This isn’t a prediction, but wouldn’t
it be crazy if the Saviors came and took all
their supplies at some point in the past and
that’s what induced them to cannibalism.
Negan took all their food.
Number 7 - The people are at Terminus are
actually a cannibalistic cult.
Here’s where we need to distinguish the
act of eating human flesh from what happens
in that weird shrine.
If they were just cannibals they would eat
people out of extreme necessity.
The people at Terminus sitting around that
grill seemed like they were very well fed.
Meaning they probably overate.
Like they ate steak three times a day, when
they probably could have survived on a fraction
of that.
In order to get all that meat, they would
have had to have killed a lot of people, if
you look at the bones on that tarp Rick runs
by, not only are there remains of several
people, they look recent.
Old bones would have been way more bleached
looking and there wouldn’t be any blood
left on them.
By the way, Rick definitely took a long look
and saw that they were human bones.
Even if he hasn’t said anything yet.
The ritual aspect of whatever is going on
is what the real mystery is.
I’m actually wondering if they’re worshipping
something ethereal like the Virus or if they’re
praying to a god.
I look forward to Rick trapping Gareth in
a classic evil guy monologue where he explains
their whole plan.
Incredibles shout out anyone?
You caught me monologuing!
Number 6 - Denise Crosby’s Mary leads them
with Gareth, but there is no big bad.
Gareth is definitely not a big bad like the
Governor, but he does have authority.
And from the way everyone treated Denise Crosby,
it looks like she’s the evil Hershel of
their group.
I sense a nice dicotomy between the prison
and Terminus.
As in Terminus is just an evil universe version
of the prison.
Start looking for who everyone’s evil twin
is.
If this were Star Trek they’d all have beards.
Speaking of which, let’s talk about Denise
Crosby.
They wouldn’t cast someone like her in a
throwaway role, I think it’s just more evidence
that Terminus is ruled by a council.
I’d call them the Legion of Doom, but that’s
really what the Saviors are.
Number 5 - One of the survivors has probably
eaten some people meat.
A lot of people thought the voices coming
from that other container were Beth, Carol
and Tyreese.
But they sound too different to be them.
I think they’re going to be redshirt characters
that Rick and the survivors will watch get
sacrificed in episode 1.
Terminus is threatening because of all those
guns, they need to witness someone getting
eaten for it to become horrifying.
Who else noticed how many times Rick and Michonne
talked about being hungry, about how there
was no food.
They have to eat at some point, and for the
time being, they can only eat what the Terminus
people feed them.
And what do they have to give, people meat.
I just feel like at least one of the survivors
has already taken a bite of steak without
realizing what it was.
I’d say Abraham would be my first candidate.
Something about him just screams steak and
potatoes.
Number 4 - They will make it to Alexandria,
but not till the end of the season.
All Abraham has been talking about since he
appeared has been Washington.
The traincar they were locked in had a giant
A on it and had a NW for Northwest.
We all expect them to get there eventually.
But based on the casting upgrades that included
Gareth, it became pretty clear that Alexandria
is much further in the distance.
I think it’s a good thing.
Once they get there it’s all Saviors then
downhill.
Right now in the comics there’s the All
Out War storyline.
I think for them to jump to that before Season
6 or 7 is just way too soon.
If you’re reading the comics then you can
take comfort in something Robert Kirkman said.
Basically that all of the things you think
are coming are coming, the difference is that
the show remixes stuff.
So you still get those big comic book things,
they just might not be exactly the same.
For example the character Gareth is a twist
on is probably a version of Chris, the leader
of the Hunters.
If you haven’t you should check out Volume
11 Fear the Hunters.
It covers all things cannibalism.
Number 3 - Rick will say his famous line in
episode 1.
Rewind a little in the comics from the Hunters.
Rick has this famous line, “We Are the Walking
Dead”.
I kept expecting him to say it in the finale,
in a twist from the comic.
Like as a battle cry.
He ended up saying they messed with the wrong
people, but I’m holding out hope he’ll
say it in season 5.
Number 2 - Beth’s storyline in Season 5
will follow a different path from the Survivors
and we won’t see her as much.
Robert Kirkman has said that they are remixing
things from the comics, and didn’t confirm
or deny anything about who took her.
But we will see her.
Just not with the Survivors.
I think it was Jesus that took her, or they’ll
combine his character with father Gabriel.
Either way she’s on her way to Alexandria.
Even if she doesn’t get there right away,
she’ll still spend most of the season apart
from the Survivors.
That foreshadowing from the finale, there’s
a new sheriff in town, implies that she’ll
become a little more of a badass.
I think that’s what all those hunting scenes
with Daryl were about and her moment with
the spoon.
By the time she is reunited with the Survivors
I think she’ll just be more like Carol,
a slightly less hardcore version of Carol.
No matter how awesome Beth gets, I don’t
think she’ll be the kind of person that
could kill a child.
Number 1 - We won’t see Negan until they
get to Alexandria.
Which may not happen until the very end of
the season.
Based on Gareth being upgraded to cast regular
I think he’s going to be around for a long
time and in a lot of episodes.
Meaning there really isn’t room in the narrative
for Negan yet.
Him showing up is entirely dependent on when
they arrive at Alexandria, and even then it
might be another repeat of what happened in
this finale.
You get a flash of Alexandria for 5 minutes
and we get introduced to him and that’s
it.
They leave all the character development and
explanations for Season 6.
It even possible that they could push him
all the way to the end of season 6.
AMC has had a recent history of sticking to
about 7 seasons.
Or like with Mad Men where they do 7 seasons
and split it into two years to make it seem
like 8 seasons.
Now it’s your turn, let me know what your
predictions are for season 5.
How long do you think they’ll stay at Terminus?
And if Beth’s story is going to be apart
from them, is she being taken to Alexandria?
My next bonus video will probably post next
week.
Now that Game of Thrones is so close I’m
going to focus more on that.
Be sure to subscribe to get all of that.
And leave me suggestions for anything you
want in those bonus videos.
Right Now click here for my finale video and
click here for the Q&A.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!